spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch can see you
right through to dinner now to start the
sort of spicy fragrant tomato sauce get
your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
let them embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do it all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season and oven proof dish
for my spicy egg crunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one replace that in the center
get your mix
and place that on top of the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
Montgomery cheddar I want to grate the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top and we'll season that
with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg which is salt
such a pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
just a little bit of coriander to finish
it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started
spicy Mexican eggs in a crispy tortilla
shell
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
that's cool a butt
the slow you cook it the more juice it
is and it's great for big parties
because you just come along and get your
fork and shred it a delicious Smoky
mayonnaise and you're away onions into
half and half again okay I'm Gonna Leave
the roots on okay because I want this to
sit underneath the pool
it gives a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I would like you to crush the
garlic we're going to make a really nice
little paste
okay
[Music]
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more Crush
come on Mickey
oh sorry
cut there now this
there's a beauty paprika smoke paprika I
love it so three nice tablespoons in
okay
two large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please
and pepper good girl
[Laughter]
so I'm going to form a nice paste now
olive oil in
mix that some thyme in there so we've
got a sort of fragrant rub time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pull that all over it
now
this is where you've got to be really
quick
okay
rub that massage
look at that
just drizzle a little touch of olive oil
on top of that for me I keep the pork
nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right quite easy as well to
make it's very easy five and a half to
six hours in the oven at 140.
while our pork butt slowly roasts Meg
and I are gonna pimp some shop bought
mayonnaise
I don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things you can twist
yeah there's so many things so many
exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper
and
a little touch of Honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste
I love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge great for open sandwiches yeah
can you use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
I've never had this before it's so good
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finally die sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
[Music]
taste and gently combine before a final
sprinkling of grated Greer
simple cheesy crushed potatoes are
equally delicious served hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off I'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing
fresh sugar in teaspoon of sugar please
die
a little small
cider vinegar there you go
finely chopped it up
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please thank
you and stop and then mix that up with
me
okay
a little taste
so good and it's kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
with poly now let me the pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious
before we go to the table just a little
bit honestly
don't tell mum thank you
good idea I'm gonna do it
that
so yeah you promised me you don't give
the recipe to your boyfriend that's good
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
I'm quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw